I have enjoyed every single outing as
Loki
he was someone who was essentially a
prince in a royal family who found out
he didn't belong in that family and
actually in his lineage is much darker
which is how his position as an
antagonist is born what's unique about
this experience is as an actor when you
build the character you build it and
play it and inhabit at once it's very
very very rare to come back even once
let alone twice three times four times
in my case five times and reinterpret
and reinvigorate the character his
charming is mischievous
he's witty he's clever and funny but all
of those things are on top of this
vulnerability in this pain but that's
Loki's complexity is Loki is someone
who's always dancing on the line between
good and bad and I think that's have
been really enjoyable for me to play
[Music]
after the play you're gonna be shooting
your TV series yes yes which is crazy
it's amazing yes and I can't share this
with you working with them on on what
it's gonna be what the contents gonna be
what the the you know the meat and
potatoes of the story is gonna be the
the tone the context the different
challenges I mean is so exciting can we
take it that we know what Rick and Morty
writers your showrunner so is that
indicative of the tone that it's maybe a
little more comedic than oh it's yeah
there'll be humor in it for sure yeah
it's funny yeah but this also
it's the loci of Tremonti 2012 based
yeah so he's still he's not redeemed
yeah yeah yeah right so a little bit
more of the nefarious that's why he
starts okay yeah but by end of the six
hours he's when he's in our whole other
you would hope set of challenges
but the point is that there's a sense of
I know this character now I feel that
the audience knows him and playing him
and playing him truthfully but but
presenting him with new challenges which
then and have to change him in different
ways is the most exciting aspect
yeah so there's this you've got his very
specific gifts his intelligence his
treachery his mischief his magic and
then presenting and seeing him go come
up against more formidable opponents and
the like of which he has never seen or
known everybody is Charlie we have an
early promo for the Loki series Tom
Hiddleston explaining a little bit about
what the story is going to be the
villains he's going to be facing and how
they're making it so we'll break it down
we're doing the Avengers end game and
the spider-man far from home blu-ray
giveaways all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
Loki Theory on the video and because all
these TV shows are launching on the
Disney Plus streaming service when they
roll that out I'll start doing giveaways
for memberships to that but just
breaking this down top bob style biggest
things number five the showrunners of
the Loki series are coming from Rick and
Morty which makes me so much more
excited what an exciting life you lead
and they're not saying that Dan Harmon
in Justin roiland
are running the Loki TV series they're
saying that other people who wrote for
earlier seasons of Rick and Morty are
now running the Loki series but it won't
be like Rick and Morty with the Loki
character it'd be a little more like
quantum leap with him jumping through
time using the tesseract we'll talk
about that in a second too because it
almost sounds from the pitch like
they're breaking some of the rules about
what the tesseract is capable of but
there are other ways to time travel in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that they
haven't tried using yet number four the
really interesting idea is that they
never really tell Tom Hiddleston about
what's happening to the Loki character
only just a couple weeks before they
shoot most of his stuff and that
includes all the movies that he's worked
on through Thor the dark world so I had
to cut this way down it's a way longer
version of a conversation that he's
having talking about his character but a
lot of it isn't quite relevant to the
Loki TV series so we just cut that stuff
out but he says that he learned about
Loki's death at the beginning of
infinity war a couple years ago when the
Russos had just initially developed
their pitch they hadn't quite worked out
the story for avengers endgame yet so at
that time they didn't know that they
would bring Loki back during 2012 but in
the couple of years that it took to get
to the actual filming of Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame by then
they had figured it out because they
filmed those things
back-to-back so he says he learned about
the low-key TV series that they wanted
to do they pitched it to him about three
weeks before Avengers infinity war hit
theaters because they filmed both of
those films back-to-back he'd already
filmed his Avengers endgame scenes after
they did that he said that he also
assumed that that was the last time they
would see the Loki character but then
within you know a couple months of that
before the big premiere of Avengers
infinity war he said they came to him
and said oh we have this idea for Loki
TV series Marvel was naturally looking
to do a bunch of mini series for the
more underserved characters that would
never get their own solo film and
because Tom Hiddleston has been no
stranger to prestige TV series it just
seems like a no-brainer that you would
go with Loki he's probably been with the
most popular characters since Marvel
phase 1 so some of these Disney Plus
series will be for stuff that they just
never had the time to do in the movies
for characters that never really got a
big story that's why they're doing
Scarlet Witch and the wand division show
because she's incredibly powerful
character they're just so much going on
with her that they just don't have time
to address during these giant huge
crossover movies the interesting thing
though is that they did not say what
would happen to Loki obviously at the
end of his TV series and they didn't say
whether or not there would be a season
two right now I'm not expecting one
because of the way they're plotting
these series out and Marvel phase four
Marvel phase 5 will be the same way
where you have a bunch of movies with a
bunch of those TV shows in between them
but they're spending almost the budget
of one of those big Marvel movies making
six of these episodes for each of these
different character TV shows so imagine
six episodes of this Loki show for about
a hundred and fifty million dollars
meaning it's going to be really really
big so when they get to the Marvel phase
five miniseries TV shows that they do on
Disney Plus they'll be completely
different with different characters it
won't be like the second season of one
division or Loki 3 says that episode 1
of the TV show starts really soon right
after this moment of his escape with the
tesseract he keeps referring to it as
the Loki who just got thrashed by the
Hulk during the original Avengers movie
so he hasn't been caught he hasn't been
taken back to face Odin's justice he's
carrying a literal and metaphorical
get-out-of-jail-free card in the
tesseract and it basically a free pass
to screw with earth as revenge for his
loss during the original Avengers movie
normally in the comics when you see Loki
agent of Asgard or
stories where loki spends a lot of time
just on his own doing things
he's usually operating out of Asgard
either it's a future version of Loki
like a much older version where it's a
younger version of Loki like kid Loki
but in all those instances he's usually
operating out of a version of Asgard so
he has access to the Bifrost but this is
a version of Loki that still has not
faced justice for what he did during the
original Thor movie remember he tried to
take over Asgard and then basically flew
into the maw and that was the last you
saw of him till the Avengers movie it
wasn't till the beginning of Thor the
dark world that you actually saw him
sitting in prison just chilling out
doing time for all of his misdeeds so
this version of Loki probably isn't
going to be operating out of Asgard and
because he has the tesseract he can
travel all over the universe wherever he
wants number two a lot of you are asking
the really good question how can he jump
through time quantum leap style if he
only has the space stone and the
tesseract because it's not supposed to
be able to travel through time as far as
we know it but they did explain that's
one of the core ideas of the series is
it him jumping through time altering
major events in world history like here
in this preview image he's walking down
the streets of New York City I think
this is actually supposed to be Times
Square in it's the weekend that jaws hit
theaters in June 1975 you can see it on
the marquee behind him here so we think
they're gonna have to retcon the powers
that the tesseract of space don't have
or they're gonna have to find some way
for him to combine that with his magic
or some other Asgardian technology or
other really advanced technology to then
travel through time like I said they
still think that he's dead on Asgard
until Thor tells them so it's not like
he can waltz up behind Heimdall and use
the Bifrost technology to quantum leap I
would like to see what would happen if
you combine the space stone powers with
the powers of the Bifrost so until they
give us a lot more information I would
just lean more towards them retconning a
little bit about what the space stone is
actually capable of but there are six
episodes total as he says they haven't
said what all the major events are going
to be but I did love his comment about
who the villains of the series would be
number one he says that Loki will face
some of his most formidable opponents
beings he's never faced before
challenges he's never faced of all of
the things that it would be cool for
them to do that includes magic based
characters for the most part within the
last couple of hundred years the ancient
one would have been sorcerer supreme he
was
really easy for dr. strange to track
Loki when he came to earth so it'd be
pretty easy for the ancient one to
realize what Loki is doing changing
world events using the space stone even
if he didn't know exactly what he was
doing the ancient one can detect the
presence of an infinity stone but
there's the Enchantress various demons
cosmic beings like the Watchers watching
Loki mess with the timeline and because
he's time-traveling you know small hope
I'm not expecting it but it would be
really cool if they lay in some Easter
eggs for king to conquer whether or not
they actually cross paths but I think
because of the more comedic tone when he
says formidable opponents he's also
probably talking about the people that
he's trying to mess with in these big
world history events you also have
Scrolls you have the pink skank read
they said that they had been to Planet
Earth before the events of the Captain
Marvel movie so there could be Scrolls
on planet earth hiding out trying to
influence the world running into Loki
while he's also trying to influence
major events but let me know in the
comments who are these formidable
opponents that you think that Loki is
going to face who are the villains of
his serie is going to be and what's
gonna happen in a couple weeks is
they're doing that Marvel phase four d23
panel they'll probably show off footage
for the upcoming movies like The Black
Widow movie maybe some more concept art
from the Eternals so I'll do a video for
that and we'll get some more details
about what's going on with Disney Plus
and all these Avengers spin-off TV
series of course I'll be doing episode
videos for all this stuff when it gets
here and I will do more videos about
them when we get more details but it's
still pretty early on leave all your
requests and your big questions in the
comments and I'll try to answer them
congratulations King Darko you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Black
Panther to name more video and click
here for my video on the ending of the
boys season 1 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you